as far as companies go few will ever
achieve status as strong as cupertino's
pride apple however despite that nature
there's still a lot of stuff scattered
around apple's decades-long history
that's a lot less well-known as compared
to the rest of their achievements like
did you know that almost every apple
promotional image displays the time 941
that when the first iphone was being
made there was so much secrecy around it
that the hardware team never met the
software team and the project was under
the code name m68 or that steve jobs was
known as employee number zero while at
apple and my personal favorite did you
know that apple used to deliver products
to consumers in limousines at one time
we could go on and on about did you
knows from apple's history and so today
we're going to be exploring 10 such
things about apple that you might have
never known starting with one it was
funded by selling a scientific
calculator nowadays apple is known for
having more workable cash than the gdps
of entire countries but as you can
imagine back in its heyday that wasn't
the case in fact to gather money just to
buy the parts needed to build the first
few orders of the apple one steve jobs
had to sell his volkswagen van and
wozniak then a hewlett-packard employee
had to sell his hewlett-packard 65
scientific calculator and while for
today's kids that might sound like a
really small investment especially
compared to job selling an entire car
you may be surprised to know that back
in the day that calculator would have
fetched something like 500
you see back in 1976 a scientific
calculator was as advanced as everyday
computing got and most cost as much as a
laptop with a hewlett packard 65 that
wozniak sold actually being marketed as
the smallest programmable computer ever
and well if you look through old
catalogs that particular model did in
fact retail for a whole 799 dollars
nothing short of prime laptop territory
nowadays it's interesting to look back
at how that one calculator being sold
indirectly led to the demise of
calculators in general since nearly 30
years after that calculator was sold the
world was introduced to the iphone the
de facto bane of technology from that
era although i do wonder how much that
calculator would fetch if it came up on
ebay today what do you guys think let me
know in the comments below two they've
fought with the beatles now at first
glance there couldn't be two entities
further in scope than a tech company and
a classic rock band but both of them
have one very special thing common
between them the apple branding you see
before apple computers was founded in
1976 in 1968 apple corp was incorporated
across the atlantic as the official
record distributor for the greatest band
on earth and as you can imagine after
apple started to grow in size it led to
a lot of corporate bitterness between
the two groups over who owned the right
to be called apple starting in 1978
apple records filed the first of many
lawsuits against apple computers which
eventually resulted in a payment of 80
thousand dollars to apple corp in an
agreement that the two companies would
stay out of each other's businesses
apple corp agreeing to never work with
electronics and apple inc agreeing never
to do music and if you know anything
about the stuff apple has made you know
that that agreement didn't last after a
ton of lawsuits between the introduction
of music playing on apple computers and
the introduction of the ipod and
eventually itunes the companies met once
again to discuss what was to be done and
the result was a decision that apple
would take possession of all the
trademarks related to apple and then
licensed some of them back to applecorp
and with apple releasing all of the
beatles music on itunes in 2010 it seems
like the matter has finally been put to
bed three their first logo featured
isaac newton speaking of branding there
have been few logos as iconic and
unchanging as apple's famous bitten
fruit however even though you may think
the icon has remained the same in shape
since the very first rainbow logo there
was a time when apple went by a much
different image you see for the first
year of its existence apple's logo was
one featuring none other than sir isaac
newton himself moments before the
historic moment when he allegedly
uncovered his theory of gravity as for
who designed the logo it was the third
founding member of the company ronald
wayne and if you're wondering why
literally no one's heard of him it's
because the guy ended up selling his
shares of the company to his partners
jobs and wozniak for just 800
and well if it looks outdated now that
logo was a departure from the mainstream
even by 1970s standards and as a result
just a year later steve jobs hired
graphics designer rob janoff who created
the iconic apple silhouette according to
jobs the logo had that bite taken out of
it so people did not confuse it with a
cherry and as for the retro rainbow
colors that was actually jobs edition
since he thought the monochrome design
needed to look more human and while the
color didn't stick the mere fact that
the silhouette hasn't changed even once
since it was made has got to speak for
how successful that logo was
4. the legend of john appleseed if the
logo is the most common piece of
branding related to the company the name
john appleseed is probably the most well
hidden so much so that many people might
not even be aware that it's a thing
however if you start to look deep into
apple's manuals videos and web pages the
name starts to pop up everywhere
prompting the question who exactly is
john appleseed and the answer to that
question might be with the most unlikely
group possible middle schoolers you see
younger students in the states are often
taught about the exploits of one johnny
appleseed an 18th century american
pioneer missionary and gardener who is
responsible for the widespread
cultivation of apples all across the
continent and well that's basically the
entire reason why he appears so often in
apple related stuff but as far as how it
all started the first johnny appleseed
reference that we have relates back to
apple investor and former ceo mike
marcula who used it as a pen name when
he used to write programs for apple ii
and the first public instance of it on
apple items was the letter written on
the leopard text edit icon which when
opened read here's to the crazy ones the
misfits the rebels the troublemakers the
round pegs and the square holes the ones
who see things differently they're not
fond of rules and they have no respect
for the status quo you can quote them
disagree with them glorify or vilify
them about the only thing you can't do
is ignore them because they change
things and that letter the one apple
also used extensively in many different
places is known to be signed as take
care john appleseed as for nowadays the
name mostly appears on contact cards and
the like on iphone software mockups and
wouldn't you know it there is a phone
number attached to that contact as well
although to out and every geek's
collective disappointment that number
does not lead anywhere when called 5. a
history of fruity names that almost
didn't happen now johnny appleseed is
far from the only apple inspired name
used by the company and the most
prominent example of that is none other
than the mac or as it was called back in
the day the macintosh because while the
first few apple computers were simply
named numerically with apple 1 apple ii
and so on and there was even an apple
lisa named after steve jobs daughter
when it came time for the latest and
greatest attempt by apple to
revolutionize computing it would end up
being called the macintosh as for why
the name is actually attributed to apple
employee jeff raskin who used the name
of his favorite variety of apples as the
code name for the device because of the
whole fruity nature of the business and
while that's all it was supposed to be a
code name with the actual release name
being chosen by steve jobs the staff
loved the code name so much that jobs
had to budge and as far as the name jobs
had intended to call the device is
concerned it was supposed to be bicycle
which actually came from an ad apple had
placed in scientific american magazine
in the ad there was a quote by steve
jobs which mentioned how computers were
the bicycles for the mind referencing
the fact that even though many animals
can outrun a human on foot by using a
bicycle we can beat them all and sure
that's a neat story i don't know about
you guys but the name just doesn't do it
for me and that's exactly what the
people at apple thought because once the
macintosh became a thing nothing has
been able to change that branding since
and won't be able to for the foreseeable
future 6. their prices have always been
concerning although for different
reasons now many tech people have said
this before but apple is not the same as
it was a few decades ago and the main
reason they quote for that is apple's
prices which have gone up dramatically
ever since the last decade started and
while that is true for the most part
that doesn't mean this is the first time
pricing has been a point of contention
for the company in fact historically
speaking many of apple's products
especially experimental and first
generation ones have always boasted a
high price tag and the clearest example
of that in fact is none other than
apple's very first computer which when
adjusted for inflation would have been
more expensive than the macbook air or
even a 17-inch macbook pro today and
that's actually not the only special
part of the price tag because back in
1976 the official price of the apple won
was exactly
666.66 dollars and before you guys start
with your illuminati theories that was
actually a decision of practicality more
than anything as apple co-founder steve
wozniak once explained it at a news
conference i was into repeating digits
and after adding a third to the
wholesale cost of five hundred dollars
the price of the machine would have come
out to around 667 dollars and seeing
such a perfect opportunity was simply
had to turn it into a satisfying 666.66
7. they like their easter eggs if you
thought johnny appleseed was the only
gimmick or easter egg to be found in an
otherwise cold and mechanical company
you'd be sorely mistaken because while
the company nowadays is known for being
really mature about their features that
wasn't the case just a couple of decades
ago and one particularly iconic example
of that is actually the very first ipod
and the easter egg is actually
reminiscent of one of apple's biggest
competitors these days that's right the
first ipod had a hidden game just like
many android phones have had for years
now and just like tapping and holding
the software information can open a
simple game on your android phone
pressing the right buttons in the right
menu on the ipod also opened up a game
for well-informed fans to enjoy as for
how exactly it was accessed in a review
by nick triano's in early 2002 go to the
about menu hold down the center button
for about three seconds and you'll get a
breakout pong game to play while you
listen and that name would be familiar
to a few among you because breakout is
actually a game that was developed by
atari by none other than steve jobs and
steve wozniak who worked on the game
when the two of them worked together at
atari 8. the significance of 941 now
speaking of easter eggs something that
only the most dedicated of apple fans
may have noticed is that whenever apple
iphones are released they are
traditionally shown with the clock set
to 941 and while that might seem like a
random easter egg at first glance there
are actually a bunch of reasons behind
it and it starts as so many things about
apple do with steve jobs you see when
the first iphone was about to be
released the event was supposed to start
at nine in the morning and the way it
was structured would mean that the
iphone would be unveiled around you
guessed it 941 and being steve jobs the
ceo and visionary insisted that the time
that was shown in the unveiled images be
the same that it actually was during
that moment and since then not only has
that time remain consistent on the lock
screens of all subsequent iphones but
the company also pays attention to the
fact that the real reason behind the
time remains the same and chooses to
reveal the phones at the exact same time
as steve jobs did all those years ago
and honestly if that doesn't explain
just why apple is considered so far
ahead of the competition in terms of
attention to detail alone i don't know
what will 9. they created many
interesting products over the years when
steve jobs returned to apple from his
wilderness journey in 1997 he gathered
the team together for a meeting and told
them that the company was sinking
because they had a lot of bad products
but just how bad were these products
well there were some pretty odd ones
that you probably didn't know or are
fortunate to be too young to remember
lucky you let's take a look at apple's
attempt at a gaming console the pippin a
gaming box that cost more in 1997 than
the xboxes and playstations of today or
the 10th anniversary macintosh branded
as the tam a mac pro before there was
the mac pro meant to be hand delivered
by a limousine and set up by a man
wearing a tuxedo this bad boy cost a
mind-numbing 7
500 in 1997 for what was at the time a
genuinely amazing pc and while it sadly
did not make it as a successful product
for obvious reasons it is still
celebrated as a milestone in technology
or the time when apple became the first
company to create a digital color camera
back in the 90s the quick take 100 was
the best of its kind state of the art no
it was really bad the massive chunky box
could only take 8 photos before running
out of storage and even those at 640 by
480 resolution and lacked any zoom
preview or god forbid editing capability
and as a perfect little cherry on top
the thing costs
749 which is the equivalent of 1 000
today which is a lot of money for a
camera that needs to be attached to a
mac to properly function and while all
of those turned out to be major losses
for the company both financially and
resource wise nothing compares to the
sheer identity loss that was the apple
collection an apple inspired clothing
line that's right at one point in the
1980s apple decided to release a
collection of very era appropriate
clothes which might be a sure sell in
today's world of apple fans but back
then was a surefire way to ruin your
branding and so i think there's a lesson
to be learned here that even the
soberist of companies might have a
little silly history behind it this
finally brings us to the last fact on
our list 10. the company was made on
april fool's day that's right the
birthday of the single most influential
company in the last century is the same
day millions of people celebrate as the
day of stupidity because the fact of the
matter is that the company we know as
apple was founded by steve jobs steve
wozniak and ronald wayne on april 1 1976
famously in steve's garage and while it
didn't actually get incorporated as
apple computer until almost a year later
on january 3rd of 1977 this is the date
widely accepted as the birth of apple
and as far as why the company was named
that way according to steve jobs he
named the company because he had been
enjoying fruit a lot lately and after a
visit to the local market felt that the
name was fun spirited and not
intimidating and that covers our video
for today and so with that we must end
today's video i hope you enjoyed
watching it and if you did be sure to
leave a like and subscribe for more with
that take care and i'll see you guys
next time